a CBS News poll out this morning shows
most Americans are worried that North
Korea's nuclear weapons program could
lead to war
72% say they are uneasy about a possible
conflict only 35% are confident in
president Trump's ability to handle the
situation the poll was taken over four
days as the UN approved top new economic
sanctions against North Korea the US
will rely heavily on China to enforce
the measures China accounts for more
than 90 percent of North Korean trade
trade between China North Korea is up
more than 10% this year men Tracy is in
Beijing with the American goal for these
new sanctions been good morning good
morning it took more than a month for
the u.s. to get China and Russia to go
along with these sanctions that they say
will cost North Korea more than a
billion dollars each year but the
questions now are will China and Russia
actually enforce these sanctions and
will they work defiantly announced that
the north won't put its weapons on the
negotiating table despite what it calls
fabricated UN sanctions building a
nuclear weapon and missile program is
not cheap the UN sanctions banning major
North Korean exports such as coal and
iron are designed to starve the regime
of the money to pay for it money that is
also used to enrich the powerful elites
and generals who in turn don't challenge
Kim Jong Un's
near total power anthony Ruggiero is an
expert on sanctions the north korean
regime is going to have to make a choice
they're not going to be able to continue
their programs and keep their leads
happy and keep the military happy
they're gonna have to start making
choices that they haven't had to choose
before when we visited North Korea this
spring
we saw kim jeong-hoon unveil a massive
new neighborhood of shimmering
high-rises his way of showing the world
that eight previous rounds of UN
sanctions over more than a decade did
not work but this time China says it
will fully enforce the sanctions which
means cutting off a lot of the trade
that happens here in the Chinese border
town of dang dong North Korea's ability
to keep funding its weapons program will
likely come at the expense of its
citizens many of whom are already forced
to work in other countries they send
their pay worth more than a billion
dollars to the regime the new sanctions
won't end that for address the Chinese
companies and banks that continue to do
business with North Korea it's good that
we have a resolution but the next step
is making sure that all of these areas
all these loopholes all the areas that
have been called out are fixed one by
one another big thing these sanctions do
not address is the oil that China
exports to North Korea it's widely
believed that if China were to simply
cut that off the North Korean regime
would eventually collapse China has no
interest in seeing that happen because
they fear a refugee crisis on the
roughly 800 mile long border it shares
with North Korea Margaret Ben Tracy in
Beijing thank you